from newsweek.com CNN cutting Donald
Trump Town Hall short by 20 minutes
raises questions I love this they say
the former president 2024 primary
Contender to the stage blah blah blah in
a statement to Newsweek earlier this
week the network said it was our job
despite his unique circumstances to do
what we do best blah blah we get it
Dylan Byers the senior correspondent at
Puck news Tuesday on Wednesday that the
town hall was scheduled as a 90-minute
broadcast of the network expected the
actual event to go as long as 75 minutes
he went on to say that it was ended less
than 70 minutes in in other words they
could have gone longer if they wanted
which is usually what Executives do with
big ratings draws and it was it pulled
in 3.3 million viewers which is massive
for CNN yet for some reason
two interesting things the first
40 minutes in we get this abrupt
commercial and I was like oh they did a
commercial that's weird normally when
they do events like this there's no
commercials and that's it was weird for
us I'm like I guess we're gonna go to
commentary while we wait for the
commercial to pass show comes back for a
few minutes jumps the commercial again
okay that's that's really weird they
come back well that's it for tonight
thanks for hanging out we'll see y'all
later bye off
I wonder what happened what do you got
what do you guys think happened do you
think it was that Trump was just doing
such an amazing job yeah I don't know I
would imagine that's why but it's really
shocking to me that CNN would have the
self-awareness to stop focusing on Trump
when they were getting good ratings from
it because the entire story of 2016 was
them focusing on him Non-Stop and
boosting his public platform all the
while claiming to hate him because they
knew it would pull in more money for
them so it's kind of out of character
for them to try to pull back from Trump
even when the Optics are good for him
you know what I think it is I think CNN
used to be generic corporate press I
used to have CNN on 24 7. I would turn
the TV on put it to CNN and then I would
just start working because when breaking
news would happen they'd be like
breaking news a tornado was touched down
and I'd be like oh wow CNN they get it
quick and then at some point it was just
nothing but Trump and then I was like
okay this is doing nothing for me
there's no news here it was just people
opinion if I turned it off when I turned
it off and a bunch of other moderates
and independents and people like me
turned it off the only people left
standing watching that were anti-trump
Psychopaths which CNN was courting years
later that's the only group of people
who watches the network so when they
said we're gonna do a Donald Trump Town
Hall and Chris lick the CEO is like
we're going to build our our credibility
back up with with America they looked at
what was going on they looked at the
feedback and they were like we are
getting obliterated right now uh cut it
if you were paying attention to Twitter
and stuff the
Talk Amongst a lot of the more vocal
leftists was how the audience response
was laughing and and basically enjoying
the Trump show they were you know
laughing and getting along you know it
was great for them and I think that that
was one of the things that really made a
big difference I think that CNN realized
that essentially they were hurting their
Chan their arguments and allowing Trump
to embarrass them and I think that was
one of the big things for them to to uh
take them down I think that that they
the comments on CNN or on Twitter were
making making effect Matt Gates called
it a mercy rule he says I've never seen
a townhouse called like a mercy rule
before that really happened yes yeah
there was a real sense of panic you
could tell that you were not supposed to
allow Trump to kind of have that magic
back again he is in his element when
he's destroying the media when he's kind
of just breaking that mystery about them
you know that that kind of thin veneer
of Civility where they kind of pretend
like they don't hate America but it's
very clear that they do and he just
enrages them the way that no one else
does when he's doing you know his thing
up there and so when you saw the people
laughing when you saw him joking when
you saw him pulling attention away from
the host embarrassing him when he that
moment when he breaks out his own tweets
that he's printed up I mean you knew it
was done after that yeah they were
obviously losing control yeah absolutely
and part of what's so remarkable about
this is that this was not a trump rally
it might have felt like one but this is
a CNN Town Hall which means the kind of
person going to that is it necessarily
who you would expect to be Trump's
demographic of supporters and he was
crushing he was absolutely killing it
there and I think that made them really
Panic too would you see that clip where
they asked the panel about the town hall
and they're like does it bother you that
Trump won't stop talking about 2020 and
the guy goes you asked him about 2020
and they were like well well right but
you know he talks about a lot he's like
maybe you could ask him about something
else it's like well yeah yes we could
yeah they screwed this whole thing up I
think Trump did a great job and what CNN
has often done is they've taken clips of
trump out of context to try to make it
as unflattering as possible and I'm not
saying Trump does it or hasn't said
things that are very easy to spin in a
negative way right the guy isn't always
prudent with his choice of words always
hilarious but he's always hilarious and
they just gave that unfiltered
hilariousness directly to Their audience
and they have this woman on stage who's
constantly interrupting constantly
trying to cut him off and constantly
trying to do the finger wagging which
becomes much more obnoxious when you're
there with the person who's entertaining
them right extremely off-putting yes
exactly so if you have footage of trump
killing it at a rally and everyone's
having fun and it's enjoyable and then
you take footage of that and you go this
was bad I'm wagging my finger how
horrible that's kind of annoying right
but if you're at the event actively
trying to stop the fun from happening
those are the worst possible Optics no
one One's On Your Side no one is on your
side why are you trying to throw a wet
blanket on the funny man exactly the
funny man be funny we're having a good
time huh what are you doing we're here
listening to Trump make jokes in exactly
and she became an unwitting performer
right and this is sort of how Michael
malice describes trolling he says
turning someone else into an unwitting
performer which I think can be a solid
definition for what trolling is and
there became something that was kind of
comical about the fact that every time
he was talking no wait no no no no no I
have to I have to I have to correct that
yeah because you're just very nasty it
was the teacher chasing the child as the
child running through the room throwing
stuff and the teachers just running
after the kid trying to get the kid to
sit down and would you put that down and
don't get over here and put that don't
put your don't put your finger in there
that's exactly what she was doing in
Donald Trump
and it's and people are dying and he's
just absolutely making a fool of this
woman well it was wonderful you can
really see that Dynamic when he's like
oh or she kept saying you can't keep
calling it a rigged election you can't
keep saying that I'm like I can do it
right over he she has no control of her
situation this is supposed to be an
inquisition they're supposed to bring
Trump up there and hold him accountable
and you know make make the entire
audience just see his evil ways and he's
just making them look hilarious and
that's the worst that can happen when
you're trying to be in a position of
authority persecuting something so so so
do you guys think Trump's back
how is he going to pull with the
American people overall I don't know I
will say this was good for him this was
very good for him since I heard
someone's on the on the way in I heard
someone talking about it the best day
since he went to Ohio
what was Ohio the meeting went to the
Ohio wind at the train derailing oh
right right right right right yeah
absolutely this this brought back a lot
of that energy in the beginning it was a
little slow it was a little I was like
oh come on man and then in the end he's
standing up and he's like no no boy
you're a nasty woman was a nasty person
something like that is like you're very
nasty he says like oh boy are you nasty
something along those lines
because what we're getting out of this
town hall is a guy kind of giving us
legitimate answers look I don't do you
want Ukraine to win the war I want
people to stop dying oh oh now now even
Newsweek has it look at this that's a
very good diplomatic answer to that
right because because do you want to go
ahead and be like yeah we have to smash
Russia because you know we're only like
closer to nuclear war than we've been
since the 60s is what they were speaking
at the Town Hall Trump would not say
whether he wanted Ukraine to win the war
against Russia about it the Biden admin
is supported with Aid and said the U.S
might as well default on its debt
despite warning the potential or for
devastating economic impact if it did uh
I'm all for that like I'm all for
letting the default happen I'm like you
we can't just live this way
I think Trump's strategy on Ukraine I
know what his strategy is it's sit down
with Putin zielinski and say what ends
this war and then having them both be
like X Y and Z goes done that's it and
that means both parties are going to be
unhappy but the problem is the result in
this country you have to march in
lockstep with the cult and this is why I
say like the the the woke stuff has
nothing to do with leftist ideology in
its root because there's no reason why
Ukraine's war support that the support
for war in Ukraine has nothing to do
with Marxism or communism or any
ideologies or anything like that it's
just you have to be Marching In lockstep
that's what Caitlyn Collins was hoping
to guess at Cena was hoping to get do
you want Ukraine to win the war and
Trump says what most Americans probably
accepted and wanted to hear we want
people to stop dying just stop the war
just just make it stop there we go
you can't have that nope gotta shut that
down no is it as if he's supposed to
come out and be some kind of Warhawk of
course that's exactly what they want
like you said they want to go out there
and and basically be as bombastic as he
usually is but with a nuclear-armed
power instead and I'm not saying that
Trump being bombastic has always been a
bad thing with respect to foreign policy
there's a good argument to be made that
his brashness is part of why Putin
didn't invade Ukraine well Trump was in
office and waited until there was a ice
cream loving child sniffing man with
dementia in office to make that move but
she's clearly trying to coax Trump into
saying something that would be bad for a
his Public Image and also the United
States standing on the world stage it's
good that he's handling this as
diplomatically as he is thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time